how do you finish a screenplay it seems
like so many people have these great
ideas and yeah i'm gonna get right to
and they tell everybody about it
but then months go by
they're at a blockage i know you said
possibly
knowing the ending i think it's hard to
finish a screenplay i really do
uh i think it's hard to write uh you
know i don't
i don't know i know so many different
writers and filmmakers people i went to
school with people i've met in the
industry
and honestly when you ask them candidly
i haven't heard any of them tell me it's
easy to finish the screenplay
for me this screenplay in particular for
after we leave
was a different process i knew that i
wanted to experiment with improvisation
and sort of bring a sort of american
indie a little bit of mumble core
uh to sci-fi and so i had parts of the
screenplay that i knew i was never going
to finish that i had a setup i knew the
stakes of the scene i knew where i was
going to begin where it was going to end
but i actually left some parts of the
screenplay totally open
and that was for two reasons one i was
just interested in sort of loosening up
my artistic process
uh but also i wanted to um just
try and experiment and sort of see where
this story could go
so in some ways i don't know if the
screenplay ever was finished until we
finished shooting
and so when you presented um this
the script to your actors they were
fully aware that
they would really need to know your
their character absolutely you know most
of the actors on the film
people had worked with before and even
when they weren't you know i would start
with a conversation about the process of
the film that we were going to make a
film that was improvisatory
that was experimental we were we might
go out some days and get
one shot and that might be it we might
go out and shoot a whole scene and be
like yeah i don't know if i like that
let's try it again
the idea was we were keeping our costs
so low that we never had to make
a decision based on money that we could
make what's the coolest thing we could
do the risky thing and part of that was
improvisation with the actors
i've been on set a number of times in
other contexts where an actor had a
completely different idea about the
character in that scene and when
money is on the line and time is tight
you're just so inclined to
not sort of engage with that idea
because you're like i don't know
we're under pressure on budget i better
just do the safe thing shoot it safely
and do what exactly the script said but
when you're free when you've adopted a
model where there's less money being
spent
you're shooting you know on a different
timetable you can embrace that
you'll be like wow i never thought about
it that way let's try it let's do it
and so most of the actors were very
excited about that idea
uh i made a series of promises to my
collaborators
sort of giving them a little more
freedom on this movie and to the actors
i always said you can always have one
more take
you know like my promise to you is i
have an idea for what i want a very
specific idea you know i didn't abandon
my directorial voice
i wrote some of the scenes you know
pretty explicitly
i knew what i wanted from the scenes but
then we always tried things that they
had in mind
and some of those things are in the film
you know and are better than the ideas
that i had
so they were really open and excited
about improvising
would you say you're a planner by nature
you seem pretty good i am a planner by
nature you know um
the joke about me in film school was
that when i showed up my first set
i had craft service in two boxes divided
by salty and sweet
i've never lived down salty and sweet
and this movie actually was a
very very conscious attempt to shake
that up a little bit
i used to be the kind of filmmaker who
would storyboard every single frame
and i can tell you this story i remember
showing up to the set of a web series i
was directing
i got there in the morning and i said i
know every single shot i'm gonna get and
what it's going to look like
and at first i was happy about that and
i came home that night
and i had indeed gotten exactly the
shots i had imagined and they were how i
wanted them to be
and i literally almost cried because i
realized like i did not come to l.a i
did not
like do this crazy thing to
execute a shot list on time to get
competent coverage that basically
covered the story like
and i and so i made a vow to myself like
i was never going to show up to set
without butterflies in my stomach again
and part of how i did that was i do plan
i do rigorously think through
the characters backstories and what they
want the visual language of the scene
the aesthetics of the whole film i think
about that all the time
but i also always want to leave space
for surprises now
i want to show up and be nervous am i
going to be able to get everything i
want
because i'm reaching for my own cool
stuff because my other collaborators
will have other ideas
and to me that's my new measure of
success if i'm nervous when i show upset
every day then i'm doing something right
and so how was that for you then to go
in with this mindset of like
i'm gonna let it go especially if you
want to make sure that every eye
is is dotted t's crossed
this the way you solve the problem of
if you have a such a strong vision of
the film but you want to have
collaborate you just need to pick your
collaborators really well
because for me i loved going to set and
and realizing that i wasn't going to be
the only person to contribute ideas
because i so trusted the instincts of my
actors
particularly my lead actor brian
silverman i can't overstate how much i
trust the instincts of my
cinematographer julie kirkwood
who's just a visual and emotional genius
and so yeah i was very happy
to open up my process because what
usually happened was
people came up with great ideas
oftentimes that achieved the exact goal
i had
for the film and when they didn't and it
was better
i'm never gonna turn down a better idea
you know that's why would i
you know and so yeah so i i found that
this movie is the closest i've come
to having the movie i saw in my head be
the movies on screen
but ironically it's the one where i've
been the most collaborative and
invited the most participation and
that's a lesson that i will take with me
for the rest of my life
and so what was the nights and weekends
process for shooting how long did that
last
we shot this movie over the course of
four years the plan was instituted over
the course of about six to eight months
but the idea was i was gonna get my
favorite and dearest collaborators
many of whom you know work big
professional sort of jobs
but i wanted to be able to shoot without
the pressure of like okay we can only do
it in seven days because
the only time anyone's free instead we
said okay let's buy the camera we bought
a dslr
um let's embrace a method of shooting
where when we just happen to be free we
go out and we shoot a piece of the movie
and in doing so we will never be
choosing the safe camera angle that
captures all the actions that we can get
we can at least get the editing room no
there's no cost to us failing in a
particular day
we're not in the middle of this intense
you know compressed shoot
so we shot on nights weekends there were
days in which we showed up to set at
seven in the morning
shot one shot everyone went off to their
jobs there were other time periods where
for three days straight you know we shot
scenes uh because we all happen to have
time free
and the real there were two big benefits
from that one like i said just taking
the pressure off of the
system which allowed us to be more
experimental more free
but also i have never learned as much
during the making of a film and still be
able to apply it to the film
you know every time you make a project
you learn something but what was
beautiful about shooting incrementally
was
i grew as a filmmaker and i could apply
that to this film and so this film got
better because i was making the film
that way
four years do you mind if i ask the
budget we made we got the film
shot and in the can for about fifteen or
sixteen thousand dollars
and then we had about fifteen thousand
dollars in post
uh to sort of get it finished so around
thirty thousand dollars i
when i say that number though i also
like to say with a lot of favors
um you know it was a sag movie so uh we
we did i did pay the actors through the
sag system
most of my key crew worked for free or
for
very below their rate and honestly
everyone was super generous with their
time
uh in a way that is very gratifying to
me they just love the project
and i was allowing people to have more
freedom and more input than they got in
their normal industry
sort of job and i think that's part of
what inspired them to come work for me
the thing i love about that number about
the fact that we made it for thirty
thousand dollars is like i don't think
it's ever easy to make a movie
uh and i think even the ability to
muster thirty thousand dollars
half of which i got through kickstarter
even the ability to do that
is a privilege you know i don't think
that means i i realized very well that
that doesn't mean even
that everyone can do that but thirty
thousand dollars is so much less than
what a big movie
costs in hollywood and i want that to be
a message that
we can make different sci-fi movies and
different genre movies
uh that address more niche ideas or more
quirky ideas
uh and are more personal because not as
much money's on the line
do you think hollywood movies are junk
food or are they a necessary part of
culture media i like a wide range of
movies like i
love big blockbuster films and i like
obscure black and white documentaries
you know i really like it like at all
so for me yeah i'm not someone who i
think wants to call
any particular genre kind of movie as
not being cinema or as you know
being junk food but what i am interested
in is making sure that it's like a
diverse
palette on the you know a diverse feast
i the only time i'm upset is when i feel
like only one kind of movie is just
dominating the entire conversation
it's all we can see it's all we can talk
about then i have misgivings
and i do feel that way a little bit
about sci-fi when i was a kid
i would have killed to have any sci-fi
movie in a theater
and it's so funny to now like have
inherited the earth like the biggest
movies in the world are
star wars and star trek and all the
marvel movies comic books sci-fi
and i love that on the one hand but i
also have a really strong feeling that
those movies are surprisingly monolithic
they are
spectacle action movies with a
speculative element
and their main difference is how comedic
they are and i actually like a lot of
them
i think jj abrams star trek movie is a
brilliant movie i think
thor ragnarok is a very entertaining
film but i also want there to be more
children of men you know like and so
i think that my only push is i don't
want to push anybody out of the
conversation
i just want there to be more people in
the conversation
do you feel that stuff like the twilight
zone is still
is still prevalent today in terms of
sort of these raw stories with very few
special effects but
the same general idea there is
a movement of indie sci-fi it predates
my film for sure
that i think is out there the question
of how people are finding it i think is
a second question but i think if you
look at
uh shane carruth and gareth edwards like
uh
and you know and honestly you know a
whole bunch of filmmakers working in
asia and europe and in africa like you
will see
a huge movement of indie sci-fi it's
there it's not that it doesn't exist i
think the challenge it faces
is reaching an audience and that's
something i'd like to see more of is
having those films sort of you know be
seen more
do you think that indie filmmakers are
afraid of sci-fi because they feel like
they can't do it on this large scale
indie filmmakers are for i for sure i
think afraid of sci-fi
because i think there's still this
dominant messaging that
a vfx film must cost a million dollars
and i don't mean that as an exaggeration
i think people see the stuff in my phone
and they they think like
did that cost a million dollars and my
message really is no there's been such a
revolution
in personal computing in software that
uh while it's not easy it is very
possible uh to make visual effects films
on indie film budgets
but i don't think surprisingly even
though i think we are a decade into this
movement
i still don't think enough independent
filmmakers realize
they can dream in this way they can be
creative in this way through genres like
horror and sci-fi
uh and fantasy it can happen uh
i think you have to have the idea for it
and then if you have the idea there are
a lot of ways to accomplish that idea
now
and then that being said with your film
after we leave you wanted to make sure
that the sci-fi was in the background
and that the the story the emotion of
the character was in the beginning and
that was my choice like part of my
artistic agenda
was to say i think it's interesting to
focus on character and conflict and the
big sort of questions
through a future lens but i think what's
great about this revolution
in in vfx and in digital you know
cameras and all that sort of stuff
is that another familiar might come
along and be like you know what i want
to make
an in-your-face vfx spectacle that even
that can happen now and i wish more
people would do that
particularly i'm excited about women
filmmakers and people of color
filmmakers who are
just you know deciding yeah i can do
this i can tell a sci-fi story or a
fantasy story
uh i can't get enough of that did you
write differently
knowing that you would be using visual
effects is there a different sort of
language you're using
depending on the genre of a film you're
making one of my goals for this project
was to
not uh do anything because of the visual
effects to not alter the process because
of that
and part of the workflow that my brother
and i developed when we knew we were
going to do this sci-fi movie was
from the writing phase and the shooting
phase i wanted to treat it like it was a
totally realist movie
uh and make it in the way that i would
make it it was just a normal drama
present day
set and the reason i can do that is just
because of the advances in visual
effects technology
the fact that we don't have to lock off
the camera anymore that we don't need
millions of dollars to do each shot
that you know the fact that we can you
can pre-visualize it even as an indie
filmmaker
so no i approached the movie uh i didn't
think about the visual effects at all
uh when the first draft in the second
draft for sure i went through and there
were a few moments where i thought
that's probably too expensive for me to
do or too time consuming but
that was more but you do that in any
screenplay even when it's not visual
effects
oh i just wrote a set piece in dodger
stadium if it's a little bit different i
should take that out so i did some of
that
but no actually one of my like big big
goals was to
not treat this in the way that hollywood
treats a visual effects project which i
think sometimes makes it somehow
different
i wanted to just write a drama shoot it
like i was doing a drama
and have the future be in it and
thankfully my brother and i sort of
worked out a system that allowed that to
happen
yeah i heard you say in another
interview with by the way she was a
great interviewer she talked about
you said moral moral dilemma in the
beginning
or in the forefront and visual effects
in the background we had a mantra on set
which was
with very few exceptions but our mantra
was if the first thing the audience is
looking at is a visual effect
we're doing something wrong that i
really wanted the character and the
story and yes jack's moral dilemma
that's what i should be looking at and
if because it's a sci-fi movie we do
need to evoke a future los angeles
and it's about you know interstellar
migration so we do need rockets that go
there
those will all be there but the movie is
not sort of always focused on that
and i think to go one step further i was
really trying to make a movie that felt
like it was shot in the time period
i often sort of say that if you watch a
movie from like the 1950s
very rarely is the camera person when
the just a normal 40s or 50s car goes by
is there a shot that's like whoa look at
that car because it's normal it's a fact
of life
but for some reason in our current like
blockbuster vernacular the camera is
almost always in awe i think it's kind
of just trying to show like look at that
look at that
but instead i wanted you know even in my
movie when the rockets launch
there's no huge punch in on the rockets
a tight close-up
there's no amazing kinetic shot it's
just the camera pans slightly and then
just comes back
because my mind was i want a future
camera operator to be
operating that camera and think yeah
rockets okay back to this you know like
i want it to feel like that it was made
in the time period because again
my goal was not to have this vfx
spectacle where everyone just sort of
fetishized the vfx
i want to tell story in the future but
it's the story
not the future that was sort of you know
most important
what do you see that your students
wanting to tell like what really moves
them
my students are very interested in
seeing themselves reflected on screen
and that means i think some of the
obvious topics we think about today i do
think it means that
they want to see more women characters
on screen and more complex women they
want to see
you know underrepresented groups on
screen different identities
but also i think they just want to see
their mindset and their feelings
i think that they feel like uh there is
a dominant
representation of life that doesn't
actually sync up with their own
experience
that it's a little bit out of date that
you know people 10 20 30 years older
than them are primarily telling stories
older than them and so their real desire
seems to be to see a reflection of their
lived experience
on screen i mean i think back to
that's this is a john hughes film pretty
in pink you know
and even though i liked the film i
didn't
see myself represented there did you
feel that growing up
i i felt that in many ways like for sure
as a kid growing up who's
half south asian half white i didn't see
anybody on screen who looked like me
uh and i used to look like me as sort of
a stand-in for a broad set of concerns
like who came from a family like mine
who who you know fought in a way like i
did who had experience in life
the way i did that was certainly just
really lacking from movies when i was
growing up
uh but secondly honestly like
i was also just i you know i didn't feel
like i fit in in so many ways
and i watched high school movies that
had tropes that just didn't match up
with my life
i watched action movies where the stakes
just didn't seem to match up with my
life you know and so
uh yeah there was a lot lacking one of
the things that i think is also kind of
magical is
how many movies really resonated with me
you know
one of the nice things about being from
multicultural background is i think i
in some ways can sometimes have it both
ways i was probably
easier for me than other people uh to
just
identify with lots of different kinds of
protagonists and lots of different kinds
of stories
because of how many of these i was being
exposed to just in my life
in general so was there one character
that even though maybe
different life circumstances but you
just felt really just resonated with you
you
felt a kinship that's a very good
question i like that one let me think
about it
i think that there when i i really
remember
watching um star wars and
realizing luke skywalker he's he's
basically a kid like me
you know like like he's older than me
when i you know uh when i was watching
the movie but like
i do remember thinking like it's so
interesting that the hero of this movie
is not a badass you know like he's
actually just like learning about the
world and i think that's one of the
things i think is like under
sort of realized about that movie that i
mean han solo is an amazing
character he's awesome he's not the main
character of that movie though you know
the main character is like you know a
character where most of the film
is just trying to catch up with what's
going on in the world
and not realizing the role he plays in
and i like that a lot
you